all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
back Darius a great place for us to
start this conversation is around
consumer spending we just got the
numbers for June and does it look good
or does it look bad what are the
consumers doing
looks great man it's great to see you
man so uh something we've been talking
about for almost a year now going back
to the last August uh which is the
concept of the US economy remaining
resilient you know kind of amidst all
this kind of recession fear uh you know
we've seen um consumer spending as you
mentioned accelerated in June we got the
June retail sale stated this morning at
8 30 and on a headline basis we
accelerated to 4.6 percent on the
three-month annualized basis that's the
highest print we've seen in four months
on a control group basis so this is
excluding uh gas station uh retails um
you know building materials Like Home
Depot et cetera is what they kind of
call Core retail sales that feeds
directly into consumer spending that
number accelerated to 6.1 percent on a
three-month annualized basis highest
number we've seen uh since June and part
of the reason we're seeing such a big
pickup in retail sales broadly is we're
having you know pretty sizable increase
in Auto Sales right we had Auto Sales
accelerate to 23 plus three month
annualized highest number we've seen in
three months so uh you know this goes
very much in line what we've seen now PC
data in recent months which is the US
consumers remaining resilient and part
of the reason they're remaining
resilient there's kind of two key
reasons the balance sheets are very
healthy and the labor market remains
quite robust so when we see the consumer
continuing to be strong on the flip side
we're seeing manufacturing and capacity
utilization actually decreasing
yeah absolutely so in the second chart
we show that on the first top panel
there we show industrial production so
the broadest hard data measure of you
know kind of manufacturing we have here
in the US economy and that number
decelerated on a three-month annualized
basis to 1.6 percent uh that's the
lowest point I think we've seen in three
or four months and we saw capacity
utilization number ticked down up to
78.9 percent that's the lowest point
we've seen in capacitization which is
the total share of our productive
capacity that we're actually actively
using to make Goods that's the lowest
number we've seen since October of 2021
but you know there's a reason why I'm
not too concerned about the
manufacturing side of the economy from
the production standpoint and it goes to
the next chart and the next chart where
we show retail inventories uh so in this
chart we show the year supply of retail
inventories as a ratio of total good
spending so you know the total amount of
um retail inventories that we have and
then we extrapolate that on in terms of
uh you know the annual consumption
numbers and right around we are
currently at 1.5 years Supply of retail
inventories now that number's rebounded
significantly off the lows that we've
achieved in the kind of late 2021 but as
you can see we are still structurally
depressed with respect to the longer
term time series we're actually lower in
terms of the year's supply of retail
inventories than we were at the depths
of the great financial crisis at the
depths of the Great Recession in 2009 so
this gives me confidence that we may be
on the precipice of a fresh inventory
cycle now when we talk about
manufacturing we also see that there's
some leading indicators here where you
think that there's a potential bottoming
explain a little bit about kind of what
a bottoming would mean and why there's
leading indicators and which ones you
pay attention to maybe which ones you're
ignoring
yeah absolutely so uh kind of the best
leading indicator for the broader
manufacturing cycle uh here in the US
economy and really almost by extension
global economy or not necessarily the
global economy but certainly for the U.S
economy is the ISM Manufacturing PMI uh
we're all familiar with that statistic
it's you know Wiley follow one of the
most widely followed economic indicators
out there uh with data going all the way
back to the late 1940s and so in this
chart here where we show the red line is
the headline ISM Manufacturing PMI and
as you can see in the most recent month
the June data we got earlier this month
uh let's take down to 46.0 that was a
fresh cycle low in the ISM Manufacturing
PMI but what we also see is the Blue
Line in this chart which is a short-term
leading indicator kind of like a three
to six month leading indicator for the
Isn manufacturing PMI which is the
spread between the ISM Manufacturing new
orders PMI and the my instant
manufacturing inventories PMI that
number is a leading indicator for the
red line uh when that number is bottom
to kind of like eight in the second half
of last year minus eight rather in the
second half of last year and it's
bounced you know stages technical
rebound to plus two so that's to suggest
that you know we're probably going to
see it bounce in the coming months in
the ISM Manufacturing PMI to pray you
know somewhere right around 50-ish or
thereabouts you know nothing pretty you
know nothing that looks like a raging
you know fresh bull market in terms of
the economy but certainly that's
something that looks like it could be
supportive at the margins of you know
this kind of equity bull market uh that
we continue to see and participate in so
the next slide that you have here is the
aggregated cross asset positioning you
have the latest and then you go back to
October of 2022 and you compare I'm not
smart but I see that the pink bars there
was lots of cash or I'm sorry there was
no cash and then now there's lots of
cash explain what's going on in these
two comparisons yeah absolutely so uh
very complicated chart so let me take it
and just explain it in layman's terms
what I'm showing here is the sort of the
Vester positioning on an aggregated
basis across asset classes and then I'm
showing it on a percentile raking you
know with the longer term Time series
relative to each of those longer term
time series and there's a couple key
takeaways as you can see investor
positioning inequities is only in the
18th percentile of data going all the
way back to 1998 and that's actually
lower than it was in the lows of October
which means investors have actually
gotten more embarrassed since October
since the lows of October
um and you so you rightly called out
that cash component that pink bar there
and we show it on a year of year rate of
change and then take that year of year
rate of change time series and
manipulate it into a percentile time
series and so the current year over year
rate of change of money market fund
exposure I think it's somewhere around
up like you know 19 or so since those 80
percent don't quote me on that but
somewhere in that area code that that
plus 19-ish percent in that area code is
in the 82nd percentile of data going all
the way back to I want to say the 80s in
terms of um in terms of the year-over
rate of change of money market fund
exposures and obviously it's well up
from where we were in the October 22
lows and so what we've seen here here is
that they're the Institutional Investor
Community has broadly sort of fought
this tape you know it's really not just
institutional investors this also
includes retail investors as well again
we're showing the underlying time series
for the U.S equities U.S rates US dollar
Commodities is the non-commercial net
length as a percent of total open
interest in the Futures and options
market so that also includes retail
investors as well so what the key
takeaway of this slide is is that
investors have been fighting the tape
they have not gotten that longer into
this rally they've actually gotten that
shorter and have raised cash into this
rally which you know if you thought a
recession was going to materialize you
know kind of in the first half of 2023
which was the consensus expectation
heading into 2020 heading into the year
we were very much pushing against that
we were extremely uh on the other side
of that expectation uh since dating back
to last fall you know the investors have
been you know kind of wrong footed in
terms of expecting the recession to
materialize in the very near term and
that's in our view part of the reason we
continue to see this you know massive
institutional performance Chase in the
equity Market because again the
recession just did show up on time and
as a function of the recession not
showing on up on time what we've
replaced in the general narrative
amongst investors in terms of recession
discussions we've replaced those
discussions with soft Landing
discussions right all the immaculate
disinflation that we've seen has
contributed to Rising soft Landing
expectations those Rising soft Landing
expectations have caused investors to
you know reassign or re-rate you know
Equity um you know Equity multiples it's
causing investors to kind of you know
support you know earning our analysts to
support earnings expectations
particularly as we look into 2024 and so
um this is something this is process and
our view is likely to continue into the
second half of the year now you've got
one more chart here that shows S P 500
Bitcoin uh what is this telling us yeah
absolutely so this is a multi-factor
correlation study uh so we're trying to
do in this analysis um again these last
couple of charts we put in our daily
lead off morning note in our weekly
Around the Horn uh here to help
investors understand you know the
positioning cycle and and what's driving
asset markets so on the chart of the
left what I'm showing is the one day
percentage change correlation between
the S P 500 and various macro factors as
indicated by the uh by the indicators uh
listed below and so you know you know at
any given time what can be driving the
asset Market the s p is cyclical growth
expectations structural growth
expectations cyclical inflation
expectations structural inflation
expectations the terminal fed funds rate
the floor fed funds rate the U.S style
liquidity or Global liquidity and what
we see now is the light blue bars the
trailing three-month correlation the
thing that's most driving the s p over
the last few months are cyclical growth
expectations and to a positive degree
I.E as investors have gotten more
positive more sanguine on them on the
economy from a single standpoint that
the s p is risen and what see is Bitcoin
was driving Bitcoin that's the chart on
the right it's not the same in terms of
you know it's often not the same quite
frankly uh so we always lump risk Assets
in this broader bucket but the reality
is a lot of times there is a Divergence
Amino in asset markets uh we've seen
that in multiple uh you know multiple
Bitcoin cycles and so what's driving
Bitcoin right now the most on a trending
basis are structural growth expectations
and on an inverse basis and so what it
means is that right now the equity
Market is celebrating the rise of soft
Landing expectations or the bare minimum
the delaying of recession expectations
relative to that misguided consensus
that we call it out at the beginning of
the year meanwhile Bitcoin is actually
cheering on the potentiality for having
a recession right Bitcoin wants the
recession because ultimately what it
means is that we're going to have a fed
and other central banks globally
capitulate into supplying the market
with that sort of unencumbered linear uh
recovery and liquidity that you know so
many are hoping for and we ultimately
see coming down the pike in 2024 and
we're I'm already out there on the tapes
saying I think Bitcoin will close 2024
or north of 100 000. um you and I talked
about this uh going back to this winter
I think there's a rocky path to getting
towards that but ultimately I think the
the investors in the in the crypto
Market have their eyes on the prize as
it relates to what's ultimately going to
cause you know the central banks to give
us the kind of liquidity that we need to
get Bitcoin you know from 30-ish
thousand to um to uh to north of 100 000
by the end of next year so I have two
other questions for you the first is uh
the FED is going to make a decision
should they continue to raise rates
should they pause should they maybe cut
uh through the end of this year
um the consumer's strong there's some
other data points maybe that are
concerning what do you think that
they're going to do and maybe what data
points support either direction yeah so
if I were the fed the FED has the
Liberty to wait right we've seen a
significant amount of Immaculate
disinflation even surprising to to
ourselves I mean we we're calling for
transitory Goldilocks and you know going
back to January with citing the
immaculate this inflation that we were
reserving and likely continue observing
but it's surprise even us to the
downside and terms of how much
disinflation we've we've actually uh
we've actually achieved in this business
cycle and so if I were the fed you know
you if I were the fan this is now it's
not what I think the FED will do I think
they will hike interest rates um next
week uh next Wednesday
um but in our view that should probably
be it because you're talking about
taking the FED funds rate to five and a
quarter five and a half percent you know
that that Corridor and ultimately What
It ultimately means is that we're
probably going to finally get the policy
rate into restrictive territory from the
perspective of nominal GDP from the
perspective of nominal employee
compensation which means they probably
don't have to go much further they can
just afford to sit on their hands and
wait and allow you know the long and
variable lags and monetary policy to you
know tighten and catch up to the broader
economy they will catch up to the
broader economy we're still on the tape
and expecting a recession that's likely
to start in Q4 of this year Q under next
year we've been we've had that view
since November of last year when we
performed our yoke over analysis and so
you know that that view hasn't changed
changed and so ultimately we still
believe that those long and variable
lags will start to manifest you know
kind of again late 2023 early 2024 Q4 q1
is kind of our expectation there it may
take a little bit longer it may take a
little bit next we don't think it's
going to take shorter you know we think
we have a high degree of conviction that
we're not going to see a recession
commence in Q3 and if anything if you
think about the district shape of that
distribution whether the modal outcome
you know the highest peak of the
distribution is a recession that starts
in Q4 of this year or q1 of next year
the second highest part of that
distribution the second highest peak
would be a recession that starts later
than that or significantly delayed so
much that investors start to believe in
soft Landing uh scenario I think at the
very low probability that we actually
walk into a recession in Q uh three of
this year and part of the reason for
that is that we're actually probably
going to see a significant Rebound in
that inventory cycle you know going back
to the charts we just discussed about
the inventory cycle if you look at
inventories in terms of their
contribution to real GDP growth over the
last four quarters on average real
inventories have shaved off nearly 100
basis points from GDP on average over
the last four quarters yet we're talking
about a consumer that is actually
accelerating its spending on Goods while
it's maintaining its spending on
services and so ultimately we may be you
know kind of on the precipice of a fresh
inventory cycle now it may not be like a
true bottomed out you know recession
level you know start of a new business
cycle inventory cycle but it could be a
mini inventory cycle that delays
recession even further again relative to
those consensus expectations which I
would argue you know since the last you
know kind of last couple of months they
have kind of morphed towards more of the
soft Landing camp or at the bare minimum
delay recession Camp you know a lot of
what's been um you know a lot of a lot
of the process of consensus being wrong
footed on that view has been priced in
we think it still has a little bit
further to go though last question for
you is are you doing anything
differently right now with the portfolio
compared to what you were doing earlier
this year
uh no so I mean we run we run it we
implemented a systematic uh long only
process uh in January of this year thank
God we did that because uh we we did you
recall we came into the year first
couple weeks of the year we were raging
Bears um despite having the view that
the recession would take
um not till the Q4 or q1 of this year to
to materialize and part of the reason
we're rating Bears because we thought
inflation would prove even though we had
that you know that we no so we we
subsequently adopted the immaculate
disinflation view but prior to adopting
that the first couple of weeks of
January we thought inflation was going
to prove stickier uh than it has
ultimately shown to be uh throughout the
first half of this year uh fortuitously
we were able to make that you know
intellectual pivot um you know going
back to mid-January when we implemented
transitory Goldilocks citing the
immaculate disinflation process that we
continue to observe so nothing has
changed from that perspective in terms
of running this systematic long-only
portfolio of approach uh one thing I
call out is you know we're at 83 of our
Max exposure to equities in that process
currently we are at zero percent of our
exposure fixed income in that process
and that's due to what we call our
bottom up risk management overlay and
we're also at zero percent of our Max
exposure to macro asset classes again
due to our bottom up risk management
overlay and what we call macro is crypto
Commodities and currencies and
volatility or those macro asset classes
so you know the the processor this has
it has it has had us you know pretty
long stocks for a while and it's likely
to continue having us pretty long stocks
for a while because I don't really see
anything coming down the pike in the
very near term that's going to derail
you know this rise in cyclical growth
expectations that strive in the equity
Market higher eventually you know we
will see um those statistical growth
expectations Peter out and kind of give
way to something more Draconian but that
could be you know one two perhaps as
long as three quarters away
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find more about 42 macro
always a pleasure man so thanks again
for having us um come check us out at 42
macro.com put out a bunch of research
for institutional investors and high net
worth retail investors I mean we have a
ton of crypto clients as well because
obviously as you probably figured out if
you're watching this program you need to
know macro you need to do macro really
well to do crypto really well so
hopefully uh folks come check us out and
then obviously uh follow me on Twitter
at 42 macro weather and we have our
private Toyota 42 Mac aware but that's
exclusively for 42 macro members awesome
thank you so much for doing this I
always enjoyed I always learn we'll
definitely do it again
absolutely brother I'll see you next
time cheers